rama ça à collonges scène de ronde dans
la banlieue de damas et pourrait s'agir
d'un an pas une exception chimiques
les syriens sont prêts à payer des
millions pour développer leur arsenal
chimique
cette femme est notre meilleure piste
depuis des années alors vous avez un
pont
ils sont besoin d'elle donc il faut
qu'elle ait besoin de moi avant que ces
armes chimiques ne tombent entre de
mauvaises mains
il faut construire des histoires et des
mêmes
le fichier que nous recherchons
s'appelle spyder web
je pense pouvoir aider votre
organisation elle va mordre un sondé si
el mokhtar
il ya beaucoup de gens qui feront tout
pour m'empêcher de dévoiler la vérité
tu nous a menti
vous ne pouvez pas rester ici on n'y
vais plus faire marche arrière
je voulais frei
je sais très bien ce que je fais
c'est moi qui te pousser à le faire
quitter morty je suis fini